it was hard you know part of it was it
was kind of like we were sad someone had
left but also sad that he was so he was
not enjoying it so much that he had to
leave Harry Styles talking about Zayn
leaving one direction is honestly making
me a little bit sad I'd say a big part
of it was was us kind of being like wow
he didn't realize he wasn't enjoying it
that much
Harry opened up about the 1d drama on
new music daily with Zane Lowe if you'll
remember Zayn Malik abruptly left one
direction in spring 2015 I think at the
time to the tour and everything was
going so well and we were everyone who
kind of got this place where everyone
was kind of living in a way where they I
think felt pretty good well enjoy yep
enjoy it yeah Harry says quote I'd say
in the moment I guess the four of us
became closer because we were like okay
this is a hurdle that we weren't
expecting this all comes after Harry
through a little subtle shade at Zayn on
Saturday Night Live I love those guys
they're my brothers Niall Liam Louie
Ringo that's it but Harry's also clearly
still got a lot of love for one
direction that was like a picture of us
that had been taken from when we were at
the show like someone's mum had taken it
and it was like the first picture of us
as the five of us we'd heard this
picture was being put in the paper so we
were like oh we're gonna be in the paper
like that's crazy
we're all just like sitting staring at
the paper and like passing around the
paper we're like let me see it get let
me see and it's not just Harry who has
good memories of 1d we know the other
guys also still support one another
you mentioned Niall he's on stage right
now how has it been reuniting with him
on the Jingle Ball tour I think I mean
we played a bit of a PlayStation is
thing in my hotel room in San Jose it's
just so nice to see him I mean I don't
know when you see someone they haven't
seen for ages and you become the same
person you were when you would I don't
know it's very interesting I still love
that here he also talked about kind of a
lot experimenting with drugs now is the
time in my life when you probably go out
and experiment and do this and you take
this making this record and we were in
Malibu saying it was like yeah I felt so
safe it was like I want to take some
mushrooms I gonna take something like
now's the time to have fun
of course Harry second album fine line
comes out December 13th I kind of went
into the second one feeling like I want
to work out how to make all of this feel
really fun okay well I cannot wait to
listen to this album if the songs are
anything like watermelon sugar it's
gonna be amazing for all the latest on
Harry Zayn Niall Louie and Liam keep it
locked to all things et until next time
I'm Katie Krauss and bye for now
[Music]